[Musique]
ans
jean noël avant kata chez l'homme
artisan ébéniste et j'ai commencé à
travailler avec mon père en 1981 1 au
moment où
l'ébénisterie commencé à montrer ce
qu'il savait faire à l'île de la réunion
ça fait bientôt 40 ans que j'exerce dans
cette entreprise
ma foi elle ma défaite
quand même a construit comme je suis un
autodidacte j'ai eu pas mal d'épreuves
j'ai laissé un oeil dans cette
ébénisterie où je travaillais un moment
gratuitement pour mon père pour pouvoir
lancer cette activité
ensuite mes frères ont rejoints
l'ébénisterie et j'ai enfin appris ce
que c'était la résilience la résilience
me permets face à l'adversité aux
différentes crises économiques de faire
face mais aussi de transmettre de
d'aller au delà et de transcender les
choses c'est une posture que j'ai adopté
et je fais profiter de mes expériences
aux plus jeunes
alors mon métier c'est de conjuguer le
savoir faire d'un individu face à des
émotions qui prouve un client
d'ébénisterie ses rentrées dans l'art
c'est rentré dans l'histoire c'est de
travailler de multiples matériaux à la
réunion je parlerai du basalte du bois
de tabac
du vacoa du verre
et bien d'autres métaux c'est pour moi
une seconde nature
c'est travailler avec mes collègues ses
formes et sait transmettre comme j'étais
mal orientées au départ j'ai essayé de
transmettre ce mal être mais transformer
ce mal est en conseil
quand j'ai des stagiaires ça va plus
loin que de les initier à l'ébénisterie
où le travail manuel
c'est un accompagnement pour essayer de
savoir ce qu'ils recherchent dans la vie
ce qu'ils veulent faire
j'essaye de les guider on est accueilli
plus de 200 stagiaires dans ma carrière
notre dernier trophée c'est le trophée
entreprises et territoires
je savais pas ce que c'était le rse et
ça fait 40 ans qu'on existe
il ya des choses que nous avons faites
et il fallait témoigner
il fallait montrer il fallait prouver en
travaillant avec l'iae en travaillant
avec d'autres sociétés
nous avons su faire émerger ce qu'on a
fait c'est une grande reconnaissance et
nous ça nous reconnecte à ce qu'on est
la départementalisation nous apporter un
accès à l'éducation un accès à l'europe
et ça nous permet aussi de transformer
notre culture en design
par rapport à notre ébénisterie et faire
des oeuvres comme nous faisons
aujourd'hui qu'ils traverseront le temps
et qui raconte surtout l'histoire de la
réunion
l'avenir je dirais regardé hier
travailler aujourd'hui pour demain